the results of georgia's second recount
are unexpectedly delayed this morning
but they're not expected to affect the
outcome
state officials have already certified
that president-elect joe biden beat
president trump in georgia
by more than 10 000 votes the president
asked for the new recount as state law
allows
other republicans are concerned that
misinformation spread by mr trump
will hurt his party in upcoming
elections mark strassman is in atlanta
with more on this story
mark good morning to you what's at stake
here
a lot of state gail for starters two
runoff elections here
next month at stake is potentially
control of the u.s senate
and those republicans that are worried
you mentioned they say that the
president's ongoing fight in the
language that he's using
as some of that potentially could hurt
voter turnout here and also potentially
threatens the safety of election workers
our investigators have seen no
widespread fraud
georgia's republican secretary of state
brad raffensberger's message to
president trump
it's over it looks like vice president
biden will be carrying georgia
and he is our president-elect but the
president
won't accept reality instead he's
attacked republican
officials in the state who refused to
change the results in his favor
the secretary of state who is really
he's an enemy of the people some of the
president's supporters have made
death threats against raffensberger and
voting system implementation manager
gabriel sterling who blamed the
president for inflammatory rhetoric
someone's going to get hurt someone's
going to get shot someone's going to get
killed
any evidence whatsoever of widespread
fraud
no god no nothing nothing we spoke to
sterling
whose family now has police protection
about the threats facing him
and other election employees including a
tech worker in his twenties
he tracked his family after harassing
his family there was a tweet where
somebody put a swinging noose
and said you know you've committed
treason may god have mercy on your soul
and at that point i was pretty much
irate i was
i was done if you could get the
president's attention today
what would you tell them mr president
you lost the state
next month georgia will hold two crucial
senate runoff elections
republicans kelly lefler and david
perdue are trying to hold on to their
seats
seats that will decide whether
republicans keep control of the senate
democrats are hoping voter registration
efforts will help
jon ossoff and reverend rafael warnock
win enough votes to swing the state
that as many republicans here worry
about the political fallout from the
president and his allies
telling voters the system is rigged they
have not earned your vote
don't you give it to them
why would you go back and vote in
another rigged
election for god's sakes and i believe
the suppressed turnout on one side
mainly the republican one because
they're only being told your votes don't
count they're not real
the president insisting there's been a
fraud here
potentially could cost georgia its two
republican seats and costs republicans
control the united states senate
on saturday president trump will come
here to hold a runoff rally for senators
lefleur and perdue
and depending what he says some
republicans here are worried
it could do more harm than good tony
mark thank you very much hard to
comprehend some of this stuff i mean
both the
the lack of a presidential address to
the coronavirus
deaths and then also republicans uh
continuing to fight this voter fraud
thing
in the courts despite losses upon losses
kudos to mr sterling for speaking out
yeah he said i was i
was a republican and i had supported
president trump yeah
the republican infrastructure there is
all said this this state went to
joe biden the senate would speak up the
way that these they're doing on the
local level
it is it's almost beyond words